nobody cares about them yeah they're
just going to sit there and go there's
those people no let's leave them alone
yeah they're sitting in garbage already
what difference does it make
let's let him die in the garbage ha ha
ha this is this is another meme of
Andrew Lincoln yelling at coral and he
says what if we were almost Karl and
then he's crying and he's real close to
him and he says would Norman Reedus
Norman Reedus is the actor you like
Travis yeah yeah that's stupid
yeah I love it I like them too actually
but dude I don't understand how you can
watch the show and was it awful okay
this says hey coral where did Noah put
the bees in the archives archives
I like these rare cards of dad what do
you passed upon selling hey girl there's
a new movie coming called constipation
dad stop it hasn't come out yet it
hasn't come out yet
oral making TV dad jokes to coral hey
Carl I met an award-winning farmer
yesterday come on guys he was he was
outstanding in his field outstanding in
his field call get it strike and he's
not standing but he's out standing yeah
you know in the people okay
it's a cat walking back Alison I would I
was eating my watch Carl Carl one of my
arif or something
continue on with that
remember that [ __ ] yeah take a break
okay we're going to talk about walking
to anymore a needle that's kind of kind
of how it's a good to me meeting you get
to troy and tinder and all that stuff
because it's yep you're a peck oh wow